[Music]
like to welcome everybody to tonight's
tactics class we've been going through
examples from the book the art of chess
combination by the Russians smash go
barosky
he was written translated into English
in 1936 I think anyway he has a lot of
good examples tonight we're going to go
through unprotected pieces and double
attacks that's gonna be our first theme
so that's what you want to look for look
for the unprotected piece and a way to
attack two things maybe a check made and
another piece at the same time a couple
pieces that sort of thing so this first
example this comes out of the Queen's
Indian defense the characteristic is the
black Bishop on b7 the fianchetto and
white did the counter fee in shuttle
with his bishop so the bishops are on
the same line they're opposing each
other
notice said both the white bishop on g2
and the black bishop on b7 are
unprotected also notice that the their
two nights
keeping the bishops from attacking each
other Black Knight and the White Knight
white threatens the Black Knight so it
looks like black is going to have to
play Knight takes Knight or black could
protect the knight with the move f5
that's played frequently in the Queen's
Indian black tries to hold on to the e4
square with the bishop the night and
maybe the either the defy the the D pawn
to d5 or the up on to f5 and that
prevents whites from playing pawn efore
which would ordinarily be good for white
so anyway we'll jump right
into this blacks turn like I said black
could avoid the problems were going to
see if he played f5 here that would
block the Queen see how the Queen is on
that line and it's attacking the h7 pot
and that the white knight can jump to g5
and then the Queen and Knight o be
threatening Queen takes pawn checkmate
of course white has the slight problem
that when he goes Knight to g5 there's
no black square bishop so that's the
Knights not protected there and black
queen could just take it Queen takes
Knight well anyway let's see what
happens
black starts off with Knight takes
Knight
now most chess players would probably do
Queen takes Knight here and might have
it would be approximately an even game
but anyway the combination is the rather
surprising Knight up opening the bishop
on g2 to the bishop on b7 and
threatening Queen takes pawn checkmate
so a black does Queen takes Knight then
Bishop takes Bishop and white wins the
rook he might get his Bishop threat but
he gets the rook fight worth five pawns
for the bishop three pawns so white
should win that so black doesn't like
that variation he retreats his knight so
he he took a piece on he took a knight
on c3 just gives to the knight back to
trade off some of the attacking pieces
Bishop takes Bishop takes Queen takes so
now we're threat this is the double
attack I was talking about the Queen
threatens Queen takes h7 pawn checkmate
and the Queen threatens to the work on a
eight so the best black can do is take
the offending night which is unprotected
with the Queen
so he gets tonight which is worth three
pawns and he gives up a ruck with it
which is worth five pawns and the author
our Russian friend says that our white
wins so at this point the analysis by
the Russian in the book stops and he
declares white has a one game well it's
convenient nowadays we have these nice
computer programs that can analyze
things a little deeper and the computer
begs to differ
he says black actually gets good counter
play yes
Knight to c6 trapping the Queen behind
the black pawns and the Queen isn't
trapti the Queen geo to b7 but the Queen
you'd notice can't get back to defend
the King side and the Black Knight is
hitting that d4 pawn so now blacks gonna
get a pawn so he gave up he got a knight
that's three pawns is gonna win upon
that's four pawns the RIC is five so
he's only one pawn behind and he has an
attacking position so let's see what
happens
Queen has to retreat so Knight takes the
pawn and notice that white can't he'd
love to Castle but that would cost him
another pawn was Knight takes pawn check
why he doesn't want that to happen so he
brings his rook over to d1 to try to
drive the night away black just protects
it with the C pawn so that's a very
strong night in the middle of the board
on d4 look at all the squares it attacks
the pawn on e2 if the pawn on T ytube
moves up then the knight could go to f3
check but it is defended by the Queen
and the knight can go to C to check and
if worse comes to worse now you can
Street F night back to f5 okay so anyway
let's see what white does okay
so white moved his rook up so the work
defends the e2 pawn and that will allow
white the castle the next move but black
has some more good moves
he plays pawn to Queen four or d5 notice
that the d5 pawn is protected by the
black Queens and now the pawn black
threatens the d5 pawn takes the c-4 pawn
and then he would have Knight and two
pawns he'd have five pawns for the rook
so that would be an even swap at that
point let's see what white does Oh white
decides to take the h7 pawn with the
Queen he's gone then he can take the b6
pawn but now black moves his Queen to e5
again if white castles he loses the T
pawn Knight takes pawn check and notice
that the e2 pawn is pinned by the Queen
so the threat is Knight to f3 forking
the rook and King with check which would
win for black so the King has to move
over he has to give up castling now the
Queen comes back in attacks the rook
which is now undefended white throws up
the f4 pawn to break the diagonal the
Queen on the rook Queen drops back to g6
King comes up Queen comes up attacking
the rook on h1 and now he opens up the
center with E 5 ok
white swings the Queen over to e7 it
prevents the e5 pawn taking the f4 pawn
because it would be Queen takes Queen
that would
of blacks counter-attack black retreats
the night to drive the Queen away
that'll free up the e5 pawn takes the f4
pawn the Queen goes to c7 where if black
does pawn takes f4 pawn the Queen can
take the F walk pawn back now black
throws his deep on up let's see
white moves his rook to f1 now the black
rook gets activated and this is where we
stop and the computer says this is it
even game White has two four six seven
pawns two four two four six seven two
four pawns are even White has an
exchange up but notice that White's pawn
structure is busted Black has the rook
and Queen coming on the e-file benfit
and anyway black has good compensation
for the exchange but the main point was
that the author well if you go back a
number of moves right here declared
victory for white but the computer
pointed out that it's not clear-cut of
course they didn't have the computers
back then okay let's go to the next
example again the theme is double threat
so that's what you want to look for I
remember this one I should i keyed it in
but anyway
white to play and win I'll point out
that blacks King is under a severe
attack the white rook on h3 is attacking
the black pawn on h6 the h6 pawn is
defended by the g7 pawn but notice
there's a white bishop on d2 that's also
attacking the pawn so naturally that
raises the possibility of Bishop takes
h6 pawn G takes bishop Rick takes pawn
check King moves up
if only that bishop on e4 wasn't in the
way we could play Queen to g6 check and
the Queen and the rook could attack the
black King now I will also point out
where he's supposed to look at the
unprotected pieces before we make our
decision what black piece is unprotected
who in the audience would care to point
that out to us so what the Queen
what squares the Queen on and we happen
to have a white light squared Bishop
don't we so maybe we can do something
with that all right so those are the
elements who in the audience would like
to say what the winning move is go ahead
Bishop what yeah let's do that pawn
takes now what
how about the rook check first how about
the rook check first now we have we're
ready to move our queen at g6 with a
strong attack if the bishop gets out of
the way now we can attack the Queen with
the bishop so Bishop to b7 and we're
attacking the Queen and we're
threatening Queen to g6 check o that's
checkmate isn't it
so we win the Queen and he wins the rook
so black won a bishop and a rook but we
got two pawns Bishop and rook is eight
points the queen is nine nine and two
points we got 11 points and we gave up
eight points so we're three pawns ahead
so that's an easy win and this is where
it stops so let's join through that just
one more time
Bishop takes rook takes pawn and then we
have the very nice move Bishop attacking
the Queen opening up the White Queen to
g6 which threatens checkmate so we win
the black Queen okay let's see who's
winning this game Black has the two
rooks on e7 and e8 and they're attacking
the pawn on e3 so that pawn on e3 kit is
pinned and black has the pawn on c5
which can take the pawn on d4 and then
white can't take it back because that
would he would lose the victor it takes
a check so again we were supposed to we
didn't check the unprotected piece that
would have given us a clue the
unprotected piece and blacks position is
the black Queen and so we can sacrifice
the rook that allows us to get our queen
with check online with the black queen
and if the King retreats he he has to go
to a black square when we get Knight to
g6 check obviously he should have played
Knight to g5 new variation oh we would
still have Knight to h5 yeah yeah yeah
that'll do it
as would yeah Knight h5 and we win the
Queen anyway very good okay so here
right here well we either h8 if we go to
f8 it still can be checked by the King
about of the night here see the night it
checks the King and then we still have
the follow-up Queen takes Queen so I
didn't matter that the King had to go to
a black square in the night could attack
it on either black square alright well
let's go on double threat well White's
threatening the knight on e5 with a pawn
Oh blacks on the rook yeah with the
Queen well pawn takes Knight didn't wear
on the other night with the ball and
that looks good that's we get two pieces
for the rook so that's probably yet
let's see oh the other work is defending
at good point so they didn't do pawn
takes Knight
what's wrong with pawn takes Knight what
could possibly be wrong with that move
pawn takes pawn and we're on the rook
and if the rook moves then we get the
night because we have the knight in the
Queen on the knight
excuse me Knight takes Knight well let's
take the knight and we're on the bishop
and the rook so well there's no wind we
let's see two four or five pawns two
blocks actually a pawn up but I guess
pardon well one of those pieces is going
there's a bishop attacked in a rook
which one you want to save the rook so
we take the bishop and then we have
bishops of opposite colors maybe it'll
be a draw anyway that's not the
combination but it was interesting the
combination is Rick here rook there okay
well notice that blacks queen is on a
white square and we're in a similar
situation so if if blacks Knight takes
the knight on d5 he leaves the h7 pawn
unprotected and the the rook can take
the h7 pawn the King takes and if it
worked for the bishop we would have
Queen to h5 check Bishop to h6 Queen
takes Bishop is checkmate so when the
time comes we take our bishop on e2 and
move it to b5 and attack the black Queen
similar to that last example so let's
see what happens
Oh does the bishop move first
and then he gets his checkmate
well anyway let's go into the next
example I hope we could beat this one to
death and not get anywhere okay let's
see I know this one black to play and
when it's ready was white against the
world champion Alexander Alekhine who is
black this combination was actually
about 12 moves deep we're only at the
final four or five moves here but this
is complicated enough so it's black to
play and win let's see
well Knight - see - that's what I would
play I like to take risks with Knights
so let's see okay now he does the bishop
takes well let's see if work takes well
then were just in exchange up right so
he wants to take the rook then the
knight forks them so he's gonna have to
protect that bishop now the knight takes
with check and look we got a nice fork
and the poor work can't protect the
night because the bishop also covers the
b3 square and Alec I'm pulled off
another sparkling combination in one the
game what's that
sure okay so we're in this position and
remember there were about five or eight
moves before this but anyway Knight
takes rook Bishop takes got that fork
rook protects the bishop take and then
we get the nice fork the double attack
on the bishop put on the rook and the
knight and the work can't go to b3
because the bishop covers that square
okay
Alexander Alekhine when he was world
champion he was considered the greatest
attacking player of his time
I do believe white to play and win
there's an obvious sacrifice here who
would kick in the audience would care to
say what the obvious sacrifice is for
white yea Knight takes c6 pawn takes
Knight Queen takes pawn check where
would you put the King the black King
after Queen takes pawn check f8 if you
go to f8 I can go to d6 check and pick
up the work on c7
how about g7 oh I got a check on e7 and
I pick up the other Rick I think HH your
only bet then it looks like I can still
go Queen to e7 and I threaten Queen
takes rook pawn check and Queen takes
rook check so let's see what happens
oh the Queen drops back that looks like
an adequate defense who would care to
venture the winning move here
the rook takes a 7 that's correct
Queen takes Knight here so Queen takes
Knight Queen back going takes pawn check
and look at all those pawns
we didn't checkmate him or anything but
we have a three nice pass pawn so that
wins that's ok where were we
all right so we said the obvious Knights
Knight takes c6 F takes six Queen takes
east six check the best move is King in
the corner but then we go to e7
threatening mate and the rook so the
Queen has to drop back to protect the
rook ah but the Queen
has to protect the h7 pond and the rook
that's called an overworked defender you
don't want your your piece defending to
critical threats it just doesn't work
out so rook takes pawn check diverts the
Queen from protecting the rook now that
we're on the other rook he has to give
up the night we get that with check the
Queen has to block and then we get the
pawn now we're three pawns up check with
a very easy ending so you got that okay
okay okay
one more of these double threats
well once again it looks like white wins
you can see the the white work on g3 is
on the line with the black King the
bishop on g5 one obvious move is Bishop
takes h6 pawn threatening or takes pawn
check oh wait a minute wait a minute if
the bishop moves the black Queen can
take the White Queen so it looks like
our it looks like our Bishop is pin
doesn't it we do get a nice check some
checks don't we what's the winning move
no your friend here was right the bishop
moves up we sacrifice our queen and then
we get a discovered check and we can
wipe out all black's pieces because we
get to repeat this check multiple times
we get the pawn now we get the bishop
now we're going to get that poor greedy
get that pawn there are no more things
we can take down the seventh rank so now
we have to be satisfied with getting the
Queen and we have an easily won ending
that was nice what's that called
windmill the windmill in chess yeah
let's see that again it's kind of pretty
ok so it looks like black has everything
defended because it looks like we can't
move our bishop but lo and behold we can
because we get the discovered check with
the windmill Queen takes and now we go
to town just repeating taking everything
on that black second row now we don't
have any more to take so we drop back
get the Queen and we have a easily won
game he gets the a to pawn but we got
two four five pawns oh look we have an
extra piece too so we have five pawns
against three plus a piece so we have
three and two point with five pawns
ahead all right and plus we can pick up
the h6 pawn with Bishop to g5 maybe
maybe not
he would have King to g6 attacking our
pieces but we'd have to be we don't have
to be that careful okay that should do
it
thanks for coming
[Music]
you